the following segment is sponsored by
the jazzy wellness
stubborn fat that is something we all
have issues with well we now have a
non-invasive solution which is perfect
for pool season
let's welcome tanya who is a medical
assistant at the jazzy wellness
welcome back tell everyone what body
contouring is
and how does it work body contouring is
a natural way that helps um reduce fat
cells you flush it out to your lymphatic
system
on first day you can lose anywhere from
two to three inches
two to three inches on your first day
that's absolutely incredible
what areas do you guys treat oh we can
treat any areas on the arms the legs the
stomach
and the back fat as well okay so walk me
through it someone wants to have it down
in their stomach they come in they sit
down how long are they in there for
um they'll be in there probably about 45
minutes to an hour um we use cavitation
to heat up the fat cells and then
technology to tighten the skin
yes we're actually looking at the
process of how it works and you said
after the first session is only one
session we have to go back for multiple
sessions
um it depends on your goals and what
you're trying to achieve
but after every session you'll continue
to lose inches
and then how long do these results last
um they're permanent so we permanently
remove the fat cells
now obviously this is a very safe
treatment the patients that are losing
two inches
i mean look at this this woman here and
her back and that's just one treatment
she's getting these results
yes just one treatment um some people
lose more than others but usually we
have really great results um
two to three inches um it's the most we
floss during one session
now someone's watching this they have
some questions do you guys offer
consultations
yes free consultations for everyone
these these before and after photos
they say it all incredible results tanya
thank you so much
we appreciate you coming on the show and
every week you always have a special for
us i'll run down the special thank you
for joining us we
we appreciate it and the special the
jazzy wellness is located at 900
south valley view boulevard suite 100
find them online at the
jazzywellness.com
and take advantage of this special deal
guaranteed
lose two inches the same day first ten
callers get 40 off a series of body
contouring call today
702 800 7406